here at geek culture we like our
electric bikes as we did a review on the
energy SSA Nova which is a very high-end
high-spec electric motorcycle but now
we're talking about something a little
bit more accessible this is the Brompton
electric bike now this bike has been out
in the market in Europe and North
America and other countries for about
almost a year but here in Singapore and
around this region it started just
starting to hit our Shores so I want to
talk to you about what it's like to ride
who's this bike for the pros and the
cons and the power of this machine is it
the right prompted for you let's chat
about it okay first and foremost we're
not paid responsible anyone these are
our thoughts and our thoughts only I do
ride bromptons I primarily ride c-line
bromptons but I have Road the p-line and
the t-line as well tested those out
absolutely love the t-line by the way
but this is a unique beast in the
Brompton family now here in Singapore we
have it in the c-line version the p-line
will be coming out very soon the c-line
version is going to come out around the
heaviest around 16 to 17 kgs depending
if you go two speed or if you go
six-speed that of course is with the
battery attached to it so this is a
heavier than what you're getting out of
a normal c-line but of course it's got
an electric motor onto it it's got a
battery pack so you have to take in that
weight consideration which I'll talk
about later on in this video so if you
take this battery pack off the bike it's
essentially a c-line Brompton now the
only difference is you'll notice or
other people will notice is that the
front end is reinforced because of the
250 watt motor that's attached to the
front of it outside of that it is a
c-line Brompton it rides exactly the
same now the version I have here is a
two-speed High bar on this now it does
come in various different versions six
feet or two speed I got the two speed
here for the review and I think for most
people two speed will be enough
especially here in Singapore where we
don't have very high hills where it's
not you don't have to do a lot of climbs
this will be enough because of the
assist that you're going to get from
this engine and this battery pack will
get you through most things easily
outside of that though let's talk about
some of the other Aesthetics to it uh
you're going to notice there's got this
blue lightning bolts here on the front
you know the bike get this blue
abrompton kind of gives you that
electric vibe to it it lets you know hey
look
it's it's got power it's got juice
inside of it looking at this battery
pack here to for a moment let's talk
about this for a second now this is very
easily uh removable it's about two to
three kgs when you have it in hand you
can charge this it comes with an
external charger you can get a larger
back to put this inside or you can use a
small bag which you can just put your
phone in some small accessories inside
of it but it's not going to be like a
daily bag just something on the go if
you just want to carry something light
also has older strap as well but when
you attach it to the bike that's when
all the magic happens and it's
relatively easy
and you're good to go you press the
power button you have your five lights
here lets you know that you're fully
charged you can set the all lights to go
to automatic because it does charge the
lights right so when you're in on auto
mode it'll detect the light outside if
it's dark the lights will go on if it's
not they'll stay off but you can also
manually override that as well but the
lights do not work without this battery
pack which if you want to ride this is a
normal c-line Brockton you're going to
have to invest in other lights which is
kind of a little bit of a downside to
this thing but we'll talk about that
later on outside of that you have three
modes for power you have one two and
three one is the you know less assist
and of course three is the most assist
um if you've never ridden an electric
bike before three will kind of give you
a bit of a jolt it's great if you're at
a traffic stop light and you want to get
ahead of traffic for safety reasons
three is where I would go with it
because you will get that nice little
boost I think up to 15 20 kilometers
their bouts then it kind of cuts off but
of course if you're going up hills you
need assistance it will kick in again
once it reaches that threshold for you
it'll it'll know but you'll know based
on your speed when it kicks in and you
hear this how kind of kind of sound to
that electric turbine sound it's kind of
cool in terms of battery life on this
now Brockton is saying around 70
kilometers on the first setting and
about 30 on the third setting now from
my experiences you can go a little bit
longer than what brompton's claiming
again it's that stop and go stop and go
it depends on how much the battery is
being used now if you're constantly
having to push this more and more and
more less battery life but of course if
you're stopping going out with traffic
lights and it's you know it stop lights
or stop signs whatever the case may be
you'll get a little bit more you know
distance out of the bike than what
Brompton claims they're being
conservative I like that I appreciate it
it's always going to get a nice surprise
versus a not so good surprise but again
it takes about two to three hours to
charge this battery pack up with the
charger that's included with the bike
but you can get faster ones out there so
you can keep that in mind but that's
essentially the Brompton electric bike
but I'll talk to you about some of the
uniqueness of this bike here in
Singapore now Singapore we are quite
strict on electric uh bicycles case in
point you need to have a separate
license not something you could take
online doesn't cost a lot of money to do
that and you can get it within a day
it's very easy to do but with this
license plate because every electric
bike has to have a license plate on it
you can only ride this on the road or in
park connectors so if you're on a foot
path you're not legally allowed to ride
this bike now here's the catch though
which is not answered here in Singapore
yet if you take the battery off
this is essentially a normal bike can
you then ride it on a footpath I haven't
tested that theory out yet I'll ask
traffic police and see what they have to
say about that but again this is a
sunlight of a new technology I know
we've got a bird going what are we going
to do we're in nature these birds come
around we pay extra for them but if you
take the battery off it's a normal bike
so then what happens to that well that
remains to be seen we'll find out later
on and hopefully I don't get a ticket
for it this lock on here that you see
here this is given to us by our LTA land
transport Authority if you're not in
Singapore you don't know who they are
they're basically our governing body for
anything that's on the roads that lock
needs to stay there because that means
it's approved to be on the roads so a
little bit of a you know a little extra
point for you there I don't even know
that only make it into the video I'm
just telling you anyway outside of that
let's get on the bike let's ride this
bad boy around and let's talk about what
it's like to be on the roads with this
electric Brompton
[Music]
foreign
before we continue here's a message from
our sponsor
this video is brought to you by MSI meet
the summit E6 then flip featuring the
latest 12th gen Intel Core i7 processor
RTX 30 series graphics and a 16 inch
Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel with a
360 degree hinge it lets you unleash
maximum productivity with up to 11 hours
of battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
alright so right now I'm on level one
and the assist is really nice right off
the go it's not too powerful I would
definitely recommend anybody first
getting on this bike is to go for the
number one setting to get used to it
then of course you can set it higher as
you want to go one of the things I wish
were on the bike were actually
controllers into the handlebars to
adjust the power output of the battery
now again that'll probably be extra
cables or whatever the case may be I
wish it was Wireless or Bluetooth that'd
be nice to have so you can just say Okay
I want to adjust from one two and three
or adjust the lights from automatic to
manual fuel or to turn off
versus having to reach down on the
Brompton
and do this
so now here is level three and I'm going
up this hill and
I used to stay here in Sentosa quite
often and this hill was always quite
challenging
but now for me
I'm just kind of coasting on up
no issues at all
this is very smooth very easy very very
enjoyable
I think that's what the whole essence of
this bike is are just being enjoyable
inconvenient easy to ride around
see that I'm not even Broly you know
catching my breath but usually on a road
bike I'd be out of the saddle right now
you know pushing up the hill
out of the two speed to a six-speed
obviously the two speed is gonna be a
lighter bite
but
I wouldn't mind a three or a four speed
honestly to be frank with you because
if I need a heavier gear it's available
for me versus right there with two I'm
going down the hill but I'm just
spinning
because there's no heavier gear for me
to latch on if I want to get more speed
but
I guess in a blunt and it's not about
speed it's about enjoying the ride oh
man you know once you go Electric
you can get spoiled real easily
but yeah
I could definitely see myself owning one
of these it's a lot of fun we
imagine if they made a t-line electric
bike
I'd buy that oh hell yeah I would that's
a short fun ride with the electric
Brompton
I will go to my final thoughts all right
guys so final thoughts on the Brompton
electric
um I enjoy this bike I like the assist
at a standstill now of course we're on
level three it can really take off but
if you're in traffic or at a stoplight
and you've got traffic behind you you do
not want to get sandwiched in by cars
and motorcycles you want to be ahead of
the pack so you can at least rear to the
right or the left depending on what
country you're in that's going to add
towards safety a couple of things to
talk about in terms of not would say
cons but I wish there were some
improvements on of course the weight of
this bike you can get the p-line version
but it is a bit more expensive but
depending on your budget I wish it was a
little bit lighter but again there has
to be some stability due to the power
and due to the the torque that's on this
engine also uh the battery pack it's um
It's relatively okay but if you're going
to keep this battery pack on you're
going to fold the bike up it will tilt
over so I would recommend if you're
going to keep this completely folded up
take the battery pack off only put it on
when you need it especially uh if you're
going to be tightening up this little
knob here as well it does hit the
battery back at the back a little bit so
it's a little little bit of a nuisance
but again put the battery pack on last
no issues with that outside of that
thumb and I like the bike I think it's
fun I think it's a great assist for a
lot of people out there that maybe don't
have the power or don't have the legs to
get you where you want to go if you're
going to the office you don't want to
sweat a lot this bike will definitely
Aid in that regard you will feel the
weight though so if you're someone that
does carry your bike a lot with you
you're going on trains you're going on
buses and you're not that strong this
may be something that you have to
consider now of course uh I'm okay I
would offer the P line if I had the
budget because that is a little bit
lighter but to each their own on that
but I gotta say I really enjoy this bike
I you know there are times when I was
going on the Flats I Wish It gave me a
little bit more system I really want to
just mash it and just go full on out but
again that's a safety situation because
you don't want to go too fast and lose
control of the bike because brompton's
the way this wheels are as being smaller
and the handlebars being a little bit
more narrow it can get Twitchy so too
much power is not a good thing but
otherwise I really like it and I could
definitely see something like this in
the Arsenal if I want to just commute
and not break in Singapore we are in a
hot climate we sweat no matter what
we're doing and a bike like this
definitely does come in handy anyway
those are my thoughts on electric
Brompton let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below if you like
this review check out more of our videos
right here hey Brompton if you're
watching this video
you're probably already thinking about
it you guys are already
probably thinking about the next version
of the electric bike but a t-line with
these badass awesome